midi les premiers clients sont arrivés
déjà le personnel s'affaire en cuisine
et en salle un service tout comme
d'habitude et pourtant dans quelques
jours le Dentan sans sererrois se sépare
de son étoile Michelin de temps en temps
on se permet une petite folie mais là le
on avait pas encore essayer l'entend en
serroi donc il fallait en profiter
pendant qu'il y avait l'étoile le
concept jusqu'à présent me plaisait donc
sil continue sur la même lignée je
reviendrai référencé dans le guide rouge
depuis 2009 les frères rtif avaient
repris ce restaurant il y a 10 an
aujourd'hui ils se lancent de leur plein
gré dans un nouveau concept moins
élitiste avec une formule déjeuner
meilleur marché ça a été un grand
bonheur d'avoir cette étoile pendant
pendant 6 ans et on l'a exploité on a
pris beaucoup de plaisir mais je crois
qu'au fond de nous-même ce qu'on avait
envie c'était de faire un bistro et on a
envie de retourner à ça tout le chichi
tout le blabla tout le tralala à mon
avis c'est c'est c'est superficiel donc
nous on va se concentrer sur l'essentiel
on va faire une belle recette une belle
assiette un joli verre on va sortir une
belle bouteille de la cave comme si on
devait recevoir nos beaux parents pour
la première fois voilà on veut que tout
soit parfait mais mais dans la
simplicité quant à la décoration elle
sera plus tendance exite les nappes et
autres fioritures un mur sera abattu
pour laisser place à une cuisine
américaine les cuisiniers travailleront
sous l'œil des clients on va se
concentrer sur des bêtes sur des
volailles
labellliser on va faire un petit peu un
tour de France avec tout ce qu'on a de
meilleur dans nos belles régions
françaises je pense à l'agneau du
cerille je peux penser aussi régional
avec nos poulets pâtes noir du Berry
mais cela dit on va
enlever un petit peu le superflu si j'
dire pour revenir à des choses très
essentielles au niveau de l'assiète le
restaurant rouvrira ses portes mardi 10
mars avec un nouveau nom révélé le jour
de l'ouverture les nostalgiques pourront
y déguster ce samedi un dernier menu
spécial
Saint-Valentin